plucked from stormy Mediterranean Seas
this week these young men have escaped
the fighting in Sudan
this southernmost Italian island is
braced for a potentially record-breaking
summer of Migrant arrivals
the Sudanese sailed from Tunisia where
there's a sophisticated and profitable
smuggling Network
God willing there'll be much more work
compared to the past this Smuggler tells
us
last year more than a hundred thousand
migrants crossed the central
Mediterranean according to the European
Union
I've organized a lot of trips where
things didn't go as expected because the
boat was overweight and that's why so
many die there were no life vests or
inner tubes a hundred people lost their
lives in two trips
lamp produces migrant Holding Center
managed by a local Cooperative has
struggled to handle the large volume of
arrivals so now the Red Cross has taken
over with plans to provide a more
professional and Humane service it's in
charge of us to re-ensure them and tell
them that they are safe because from
their their eyes we realize that we they
need the people that say to them they
are you are finally safe the Smugglers
say they're also improving their
operations
you see to stop the loss of life we've
reorganized how we work we've got rid of
the risks that might cause a boat to
sink before we didn't have people who
could read a compass now we look to
assign a captain who knows how to use
one and we don't overload boats anymore
it's all safety first
those who make it now face a more
hostile reception from Italy's
nationalist government
newcomers will find it much harder to
get a two-year special protection
residency permit if they don't qualify
for full Asylum
prime minister Georgia Maloney won power
last year promising to crack down on
boat migrants Human Rights Watch calls
Italy's new immigration law repressive
and inhumane it's intended to dissuade
migrants from coming here it's not
having any effect more than 45
000 people have arrived in Italy since
the start of this year it was 12 000 in
the same period last year
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera lampedusa Italy
Paul Bunyan now joins us live from lamp
producer Bernard you mentioned that
Italy's been trying to dissuade migrants
how exactly is are they doing that and
is it having any effect at all
well one of the policies the
government's now enacting this
nationalist government in Italy is this
idea that rescue ships will have to dock
at specific ports designated to them by
the authorities in Italy they can't go
to the nearest Port from where they've
just rescued migrants and they can also
only take one group of migrants at a
time they can't look for others who
might be nearby in similar Waters this
is because the Italian government
believes that these NGO rescue ships are
about 11 of them at sea at the most they
encourage prospective migrants to make
the crossing but the reality is that
there were 105
000 migrant Crossings into Italy across
the Mediterranean last year and only
about 10 percent of those were picked up
by these NGO vessels so many people are
still determined to make that Crossing
and there's little indication that the
new Italian government's policies having
any effect because already this year
there's been over 45
000 migrant arrivals that's just since
the beginning since January and Bernard
is anything being done by countries in
North Africa to stop this
so the vast majority of the migrants
coming here are coming from Tunisia and
Libya and there's enormous pressure on
those governments to reduce the number
of migrants Crossing from over there so
there's a lot of EU funding goes towards
the tunisians and the libyans in Tunisia
there's been a big Crackdown in the last
couple of weeks and we know from people
working for us over there that has been
much harder for migrants to cross the
coast guards have increased their
patrols and they're pulling back more
people to shore but of course they start
can't stop everyone Libya it's a bit of
a different story there's been 10 years
of civil strife and civil conflict there
but the Libyan government says that
overnight on Wednesdays are we are a
coastal city they launched airstrikes on
places where they believe Smugglers are
hiding out gangs of Smugglers are hiding
out they say they've targeted the armed
groups there's been lots of fighting in
the last couple of weeks there between
iron groups involved in human
trafficking and fuel smuggling an
indication just how incredibly
profitable smuggling is is for people
involved in it and another indication of
why it's so difficult to stop not only
are there tens of thousands of people
making the journey because of economic
collapse in their home countries because
of Civilian civil Strife there are
Smugglers making vast profits off it off
it so it's a very intractable issue for
the European Union to deal with okay
thank you for that Bennett Smith there
for us live in lampedusa